terry crews and i
just landed on a small airfield in the
icelandic mountains
last night he told me this skydiving was
on his bucket list
well terry be careful what you wish for
i'm very nervous it's getting really
real
wow it wouldn't be like
we've hooked up with one of our team
who's the tandem master we've got two
shoots
i gotta ask you is unconsciousness a
thing for sure
what would knock you unconscious jumping
out of a plane door open while it's
flying at
150 miles an hour yeah it's like you
throw out something
you hit your head on something crash
into each other falling at 150 miles an
hour yeah
we're going to hook him up get in that
plane and taking the 12
000 feet door open and then throw him
out
quick final checks feeling good inside
you're going to see the look of terror
i believe my mother is watching over me
at all times trust her process trust
herself
she was always proud of me and i always
want to make her proud
and today i plan to do that
to be a little closer to my mom
oh we're up here
approaching the jump site now
maintaining 12 000 feet
jumpers get ready
here we go here we go open the door guys
ready
[Music]
here we go
you guys are good to go
[Music]
oh
[Music]
good job terry
absolutely incredible
thank you thank you
this whole experience man i mean
literally sleeping
next to a volcano hanging off the side
of helicopters man
jumping out of planes i'm just what can
i say man this is crazy
[Music]
you